I once was
doing an article when I was working at
Fortune magazine.
Um,
I did an article about,
um,
power.
I actually did two articles about power
and corporations and I got very
interested in psychological testing and
how,
um,
and,
and because there was a fad,
this was,
I can't remember,
seven or eight years ago,
there was a fad for giving psychological
tests to people before they got promoted
when Myers Briggs tests,
but also other kinds of tests.
I also was intrigued because back in the
1950s,
um,
there was a fad for aptitude tests and
in fact it was concerned with the
aptitude test fads that cut will you
make white to start writing the book
that became the organization man or the
articles for fortunate.
It became an organization man.
And included in that book is a chapter
on how to cheat on aptitude tests,
um,
how to take them on,
how to cheat on it.
So I got interested in the personality
tests and I went to a psychologist
friend and I said,
would you teach me how to cheat on
psychology tests?
She said,
no,
I can't.
I mean,
I'm not allowed,
you know,
professional standards.
It would,
I can't,
but I'll give you one.
I'll give you the battery that I give,
uh,
cause she does executive coaching and so
on and so forth.
So she gave me this battery of tests and
gave me the feedback and out of it,
and of course I tried to teeth,
but out of it I got some interesting
feedback in which she said that,
that she was intrigued by the way my
mind worked because she found that,
that my mind worked in a way that not
too many other people in her experience
experience did,
is it made all kinds of connections to
things in strange ways.
I would,
I,
you know,
I leap from a to Z to m to l a to p and
I pull in things from a,
from a whole lot of,
uh,
a whole lot of sources and sort of dance
around topics until I get it right.
If I get passionate about an idea,
I swarm it.
You know,
I overdo it.
A,
I kill it.
And I,
you know,
I just go all over it until I think I
understand it.
Uh,
or until,
or until I'm bored and I go somewhere
else.
So it's that kind of,
there's not an orderly process.
It's a fairly physical process.
I mean,
there's,
I squirm a lot around in my chair when
I'm excited by an idea or you start
talking to people like I wanna,
I want to run it by them.
So,
so it's,
it's a kind of a noisy,
um,
a noisy process of seeing connections
and getting excited.
Bye.